i'm anne chappelle i'm a board-certified
toxicologist and i'm here today to
answer your questions from twitter this
is poison support
[Music]
first up we have a question from kooby
liken dude
what makes poison poisonous well a
poison is a substance that can do damage
to any living organism
or to the environment but it's really
all about the dose low dose
less effects high dose generally higher
effects if you drank six liters of water
that probably could kill you how about
118
cups of coffee in a row or 75 espressos
that would give you an overdose of
caffeine something else that could kill
you right on your table
225 grams of salt there's a lot of
things that you might not think are
poisonous but in the right dose they
most definitely are youngin wtf is sun
poisoning i thought it was just called
sunburn both sun poisoning and sunburn
are both caused by overexposure to uv
rays a severe sunburn
becomes sun poisoning when it moves from
just that red hot rash
to blisters feeling like you have the
flu dizzy or nauseous sun poisoning is
your body's immune reaction to all of
that sun damage so what do you do if you
have either of those things make sure
you drink lots and lots of water that
sun damage will dehydrate you and
dehydration is the cause of a whole lot
of other problems
stay out of the sun apply cool
not icy cold compresses on your skin
take an over the counter
anti-inflammatory agent as well
walking daddy so if one happened to
smash a mercury thermometer and then
happen to spend an hour forensically
gathering tiny dots of quicksilver from
the floor
how would one
happen to safely dispose of the evidence
asking for a friend it is very very
important that you are careful
and complete in how you actually clean
up this spill mercury can vaporize get
into the air and you can breathe it so
you want to see if you can have your
windows open please don't touch it i
know it's fun to let it play in your
hand but you can't do that anymore so
wear some gloves be very careful use
duct tape to kind of pound on the ground
to clean it up you can use a damp paper
towels
all of those things those cleaning
supplies everything put into some kind
of giant ziploc type bag and then you're
going to have to wait until you have a
hazardous waste collection day and
dispose of it properly do not clean up
spilled mercury with the vacuum cleaner
mercury is very very dangerous for the
environment and it's also not great for
you either from rick nowak what is the
most poisonous mushroom it's a poisonous
mushroom does it have to have the most
poisonous well if you really want to
know it's probably the death cap
mushroom within 6 to 12 hours you are in
incredible pain nausea vomiting
violent chills muscle contractions all
of these nasty things and eventually if
the dose was tight enough you end up
having liver failure multiple organ
failure and death from crimson sexta
i've been trying for so long to explain
the difference between venom and poison
when it comes to snakes
to my friends help the difference really
is how that poison is delivered to the
person a poison is administered or
you're exposed to it via breathing or
touching it or ingesting it venom
that is also a poison but it's how you
get that poison that's more of a sting
or a bite
so
it's more active you eat a frog that's a
poison
you get bit by a copperhead snake
that's a venomous attack at wildlife
defense asks what is compound 1080
compound 1080 is an extremely potent
predicide predicide is designed to kill
predators so if you've got sheep and
goats in your field and you've got a
problem with coyotes well this is what
you would use because compound 1080 is
so potent they have a special way to
administer it to avoid
killing
broad numbers of animals in your field
there's a collar that they put around
the neck so it's got a collar with a
reservoir of the 1080 right along the
neck so that when the coyote comes along
and grabs the neck it bites into that
reservoir and is immediately poisoned
and dies lightscapes asks what is a
toxicologist study just like there's
different kinds of doctors there's lots
of different kinds of toxicologists i
am an occupational toxicologist and my
job is to look at all the things that
could be in a workplace food
toxicologists for example they work to
make sure our food supply is safe i even
know a toxicologist that works at a
winery from bluebell bats google search
how to detect poison unfortunately to
detect a poison i'm going to need to
have a little bit more information if
the lead singer is brett michaels then
i'm sure it is poison if it's just bad
medicine sorry that's bon jovi if it's
party poison
that's my chemical romance caitlyn
rebecca asks so is alcohol actually
poison or
anything can be a poison in the right
dose and alcohol is definitely a poison
if you drink too much first of all
alcohol can impair your central nervous
system so that can slow your breathing a
byproduct of alcohol metabolism is the
formation of acetaldehyde acetaldehyde
is a chemical that really likes to
damage parts of your liver long term
that slow exposure over time to alcohol
and its metabolites can result in
cirrhosis and other kinds of liver
damage eventually leading to potentially
liver cancer from
lk juvenju 75 mad hatters were mad
because of the lead mercury anybody know
why i do
it was mercury mercury was used to help
make the different skins they used for
hats helped that firm mat really well it
also toughened up the fibers and was
made of very high quality felt that was
going to be used in the hat part of the
hat making process is that you steam the
hat that releases all of that mercury
into the air and then they briefed it
they said that they were mad hatters
it's because of many of the
psychological symptoms that the over
exposure to the mercury caused
hallucinations
dizziness
tremors you think of mad hatters
actually as something being from
victorian times but actually it wasn't
until 1940s that in the united states
the governor of connecticut banned the
use of mercury in hats appypaw
asks how long does poison take to work
some poisons can make you sick right
after you ingest breathe or touch it
other poisons those can take a lifetime
to really manifest in its adverse
effects something like cyanide you've
seen them eat those poison pills in
movies that definitely can kill you
within a few minutes cyanide is a very
toxic chemical and it is extremely
potent when you get exposed to cyanide
it quickly enters your cell and stops
your cell's ability to actually make
energy you see the convulsions you have
a heart attack you have different
problems within your heart and it's all
because cyanide is really good about
getting in your body and inside those
cells where it irreversibly
stops all energy production let's take
another example like e coli contaminated
lettuce you eat your sandwich you're
happy and then that bacteria produces a
toxin that slowly gets released and
absorbed into your gut and into the rest
of your body so it takes a few days
often
for e coli to really start to exert its
adverse effect that's one of the reasons
why food poisoning is so difficult to
diagnose you have to go back to food
that you ate maybe three or four days
ago and i can't even remember what i had
for breakfast 96 barry asks if a poison
expires will it still be poisonous or
will it not actually it really depends
some drugs some pesticides some
chemicals that are poisons they break
down very readily when they're exposed
to air
moisture some poisons are what i would
consider shelf stable it doesn't matter
how long that they sit around they're
still going to be just as potent as the
day they came out of the factory a2
pathways media asks what are the
long-term effects of lead poisoning
serious the problem with lead is that it
is stored in your bones as you age and
you naturally lose bone density lead is
slowly released a young child who
happens to ingest lead paint they're
going to be seen with lower iq
potentially hearing problems in adults a
lot of times the adverse effects most
associated with lead exposure is high
blood pressure and what happens when you
have constant high blood pressure you're
at higher risk for stroke and heart
attack the larson asks what is the
deadliest poison clostridium botulinum
bacteria these are usually happy little
microbes that live in soil when they are
deprived of oxygen they produce the
world's most deadliest toxin
botulinum you can find botulism toxin in
expired food containers don't eat those
botulism toxin causes an inhibition of
the release of acetylcholine
as diagrammed here so if you cannot
release acetylcholine
then you can't have your muscles
contract then you really can't breathe
and your heart won't work correctly but
there's actually an upside
to botulism toxin it's called
botox
there are lots of people that really
don't want certain muscles in their face
to contract anymore they go to the
doctor and they get an injection of
botox you can also use botulism toxin to
treat several other kinds of conditions
like migraines
certain rapid blinking diseases you can
also get botox injections to stop
excessive sweating chae young slave
asked the question how does overdosing
on pills actually work genuinely curious
an overdose doesn't necessarily mean
death an overdose means that you've
absolutely taken
too much of that particular medicine and
that could result in adverse effects
that are detrimental to life and health
another way that you can overdose
results from a combination maybe of
different drugs that you normally would
take separately that when combined they
all have the same
intended effect and then that overwhelms
your body and that can be what kills you
here's another example you build up
tolerance for a certain drug for a while
and then you stop taking it your body
goes back to the pre levels of where how
it was able to metabolize it and then
all of a sudden you take another high
dose thinking hey that's the dose i used
to take and that throws you into an
overdose okay adele pras how fast does
hemlock work i'm thinking i should
stockpile brompton's cocktails in the
1930s a brompton cocktail was commonly
given to terminally ill people it was
this crazy mixture of morphine
cocaine
alcohol anti-nausea agents
as well as tranquilizers
the goal of a brompton cocktail was to
relieve pain
and to help you be awake enough so that
you could talk to your friends when they
came to visit you on your deathbed you
also asked about hemlock hemlock is a
plant that the leaves and especially the
roots are very very poisonous so you
really wouldn't take a brompton cocktail
and add some hemlock to it because the
brompton cocktail was really made
not to help you die but to help you be
happy and pain-free when your friends
came to visit nyx blue pen y'all
how poisonous is pen ink it isn't very
toxic according to the world health
organization ballpoint pens felt tip
pens fountain pens
all of them do not contain enough toxic
ingredients even if you sucked on them
to cause serious adverse effects however
you might have a blue tongue question
from sports pundit anybody ever had
rebound poison ivy rash no just me
perfect this is not uncommon if you have
a bad poison ivy rash sometimes the
doctor will give you an injection of
steroids to help calm your immune system
down so that the rash can go away if
that medicine wears off before you're
fully healed then you can get what they
call a rebound rash that's all the
questions i could find on twitter so
until next time this is anne chappelle
with poison support
[Music]